on en parle aujourd'hui avec Achille des
prêts porte-parole du CICR dans le pays
merci Achille des prêts d'être avec nous
depuis Kiev vous étiez encore il y a peu
à barmouth et puis centre on le sait des
combats entre forces russes et
ukrainiennes depuis 8 mois maintenant
tout d'abord peut-être votre sentiment
général de ce que vous avez vu sur place
alors moi je le trouvais avec des
convois d'aide d'humanitaires dans des
localités vraiment juste à l'extérieur
de darkmouth à quelques kilomètres dans
la vie même c'est quasiment impossible
d'y entrer du fait des combats très
intenses qui ont lieu mais ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que quand on arrive
vers ces localités qui sont juste à
l'extérieur de la zone où se déroulent
les combats on est choqué par les
l'ampleur des destructions qu'on voit on
voit que il y a des hôpitaux des
habitations des écoles des
infrastructures des bâtiments publics
qui ont subi des dégâts très importants
il y a vraiment très peu de bâtiments
qui n'ont pas été détruits ou endommagés
donc la situation humanitaire sur place
est vraiment dramatique pour les
personnes qui n'ont pas évacué et qui à
cause des affrontements qui sont
incessants ne peuvent plus accéder à des
services vraiment essentiels alors
justement la plupart des 70
000 civils qui habitaient la ville ont
fui quel est la situation de ceux qui
ont fait le choix de rester quels sont
leurs conditions de vie ou de survie si
je
vous l'avez très bien dit j'ai parlé à
un habitant qui est dans un village à
côté de barthout un homme qui s'appelle
Nicolas et qui m'a dit nous on n'est pas
en train de vivre ici on ne peut que
survivre donc vraiment ce sont des
conditions très très difficiles ces
personnes ont besoin de tout vraiment
des besoins essentiels que ce soit
l'accès à l'eau nous avons maintenant
apporté plus de 6 ml d'eau dans un
village à côté de barnout accès à
l'alimentation on amène plusieurs tonnes
de colis alimentaires aussi des produits
hygiéniques donc vraiment des choses
très basiques sont sont dans les
personnes ont besoin et beaucoup de
personnes ont pu évacuer comme vous
l'avez dit mais il y a toujours des
personnes qui restent et souvent ce sont
les plus vulnérables on pense
principalement aux personnes âgées on
pense également aux personnes à mobilité
réduite ou en situation de handicap donc
il y a toujours des civils qui restent
plusieurs milliers de civils autour de
darkmouth et ils vivent dans des
conditions qui sont difficilement
imaginables dans quelles conditions
est-ce que vous parvenez à fournir cette
aide humanitaire on imagine ces
conditions extrêmes
ce sont des conditions qui sont très
difficiles parce que les routes sont
difficilement praticables on est très
proche de la ligne de fond donc il y a
des checkpoints militaires qui sont très
nombreux on a aussi toujours le risque
que les routes soient minées donc c'est
vraiment très difficile pour nous
d'amener cette aide l'humanité mais
c'est tellement important pour les
communautés qui restent donc beaucoup de
ces communautés ne reçoivent aucune
autre humanitaire simplement le Comité
international de la Croix-Rouge réussi à
aller dans ces zones proches de mise au
point de cette extrêmement difficile moi
j'étais en fin de semaine dernière avec
deux camions d'aide humanitaires ça
prend plusieurs heures pour faire des
distances qui sont pas très longues
parce que il faut vraiment faire très
attention où on va et il y a aussi on a
dans le on entend des explosions on
entend des combats qui sont à proximité
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement dangereux mais cela dit
c'est une aide humanitaire c'est
vraiment vital pour ces personnes quel
appel est-ce que vous lancez aujourd'hui
au belligérant
pour nous en tant que Comité
international de la Croix-Rouge ne te
rappelle il est clair il faut respecter
le droit international humanitaire c'est
à dire que même en temps de guerre même
dans les périodes qui sont caractérisées
par la souffrance il y a des règles
notamment le droit humanitaire
international laisser entrer l'aide
humanitaire faire que les civils ne
soient pas ceux qui souffrent des
combats et assurer que les civils et
accès à des services essentiels et que
leurs besoins de base soient couverts
merci beaucoup Achille des prêts pour
votre témoignage aujourd'hui sur France